foreign
we got some questions from social media
you can follow the minimalists on Tick
Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter at
the minimalists Miriam has a question
for us with the cost of everything going
up lately it's getting harder for me to
declutter items like clothes because I
worry I won't be able to afford to
replace them in the future how do I get
over that fear we're really talking
about the fear of missing out but this
is one of those weird fears I'm afraid
of missing the thing that I wouldn't
miss and so I would say right because
she's like I want to get rid of this
thing I know I wouldn't really miss it
but because of inflation
I might miss it later right this is the
ultimate sort of just in case and so
Ryan and I have the 2020 rule in the
minimalist rule book which you can
download for free the minimalists.com
rulebook and the 2020 rule or just in
case rule just says hey if you really
miss the thing like you could have
gotten some value from it you can
replace it less than twenty dollars less
than 20 minutes it's okay the cool thing
about the rule is you never end up
actually using it yeah we've used it
five or six times over the last decade
and so what I'll say to you Miriam is
you won't miss the missing things that
you don't like you don't like these
things so if you don't like it it's okay
to get rid of it if you don't like it
you're not going to miss it now why
would you actually miss it because you
tell yourself a story that I should miss
it or you tell yourself a story that oh
the memories are in that thing but of
course the memories aren't in the thing
the memories are inside you and so if
you really feel like you'll lose those
memories simply take a photo of the
thing and then let the thing go you
still have the trigger for those
memories in the future don't simplify
because you feel like it would be easy
to replace simplify because of what you
know you can do with that new space and
you know the the freedom that you get
from letting things go it's
it's a freedom that you don't get to
experience until you actually let things
go there are some things in life like
some superpowers some benefits that you
don't get to have if you remain at the
level of hypothetical consideration
right like you've got to let it go and
when you let it go there's an openness
there there's a possibility there and
now you can do something with it and
that's why you let things go because of
what it opens you up to in your life and
you know what you might miss it but
sometimes I think we over emphasize the
power of missing something you know I
miss things from my past so there are
some days where I miss experiences of
childhood so maybe you will miss it and
that's okay yeah but missing something
isn't incompatible with letting it go
because you know that the next stage of
life you want to move to is what's best
for you right now well you should never
let go of something that you're planning
on replacing well I shouldn't say never
but I mean it wouldn't make like I would
personally
um it would have to be an exception to
the rule but like I probably wouldn't
ever let something go knowing that like
I'm going to need that in the future I
might have been far enough away yeah
yeah maybe yeah that's true um so I mean
and you know what that goes to the
boundaries that we set up and that's
that's what we talk about in you know in
our podcast the majority of the time was
like hey what are my boundaries what are
TK's boundaries what are Josh's
boundaries they're all a little bit
different
um but the question is what boundaries
do you have set up for your for yourself
Miriam
um minimalism
is about balancing hmm
if you
you can't afford to let go of everything
you cannot afford to hold on to
everything
and it's it's not that binary Choice
it's about finding that balance and
minimalism can help you find that
balance so Miriam how do you take the
minimalist approach to this question a
what are your boundaries what do you
truly value I mean those are two great
places to start yeah and the the
beginning part of our question had to do
with inflation so I thought maybe we
could talk a little bit about inflation
because that's been certainly something
that is affecting all of us oh yeah in
fact my added value today is a paper
towel dispenser I'll get to that later
during the added value segment but
I noticed when I when I looked it up
recently so I get a picture for Jordan
so he could feature on the video version
of the the podcast the price of it has
gone up I ordered this what three months
four five months ago I and it's probably
almost doubled in five months wow and I
noticed with uh these tables that we
have here uh the production tables
they're from Ikea and I looked them up
recently because we had to make some
modifications to it and the price of
those had gone up from like 79 bucks to
109 bucks or something now we bought
them at a lower price and so yes
inflation is virtually inevitable it's
outside of your control and so we will
sometimes talk about
changing the controllables
working on the controllables
understanding the controllables
adjusting for the controllables but
inflation is one of those things that I
can't control I can only control how I
react to it yeah that's right and and
you're going to have cycles of this all
throughout your life right
um you're going to have periods of time
where things that are going on
economically make us a little afraid to
spend money and you're going to have
times where it incentivizes us to get
out there and invest more aggressively
those aren't things that you can predict
those aren't things you can control but
what you can control is all the things
that Ryan talked about making a clear
assessment of hey what do I want what's
my why what are the boundaries that are
going to protect that why and then you
get rid of things not because you feel
like you have to but because you truly
have no intention no place for them to
fit in how you're going to use them yeah
I just had this like random thought and
help me unpack this or maybe I'm just
crazy but yeah we spent 79 bucks on that
okay let's say that we had to
uh sell it because we didn't need it
anymore and we only got twenty dollars
for it I mean in our mind we're like oh
man we just lost you know 59.99 whatever
that works out to be
um however
well first off we wouldn't think that
because of the sunk cost but that's how
I used to think oh I just lost 59.99
um
but you talked about it going up in
price we don't look I don't look at
anything we just made thirty dollars
that thing's 110 that we just made 30 on
that right because we do now have more
perceived value technically right like
oh wow here's the opposite of that
though right we often think I should buy
this because something's on sale is that
the Design Within Reach Outlet last
weekend with Bex and we were looking at
this chair and the sales person comes
over and says well actually these chairs
right now are an extra 20 off and back's
not thinking goes oh that might make the
decision for us I said no no no that
will never make the decision for me sale
price is really Fool's price
f-o-o-l-s not full price but Fool's
price why is that because now it's
creating some additional impulse in me
yeah now if I'm not willing to pay full
price for the thing why the hell am I
going going to buy the thing I don't
want just because it's on sale did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcasts
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free